technology has evolved with time and
made the meticulous job of software
development look like a child's play
even a non-technical or a developer with
least programming experience can develop
a compelling application these days and
the platform is popularly known as no
code development in this session we will
be discussing the top 10 best no code
application builders hey everyone
welcome to yet another exciting video
from simply learn before we begin let me
tell you guys that we have daily updates
on multiple technologies if you're a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
now without any further ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
discussion
first we will begin with learning what
exactly is no good development
later we shall understand the top 10
best application builders and finally we
will discuss the benefits of no code
development
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now let's get started with our
first concept that is what is no good
development
so everyone has an idea on coding which
means passing the instructions to a
computer using programming languages
with the help of technical users but no
good development is into the market and
showing positive results by using
non-technical users to create
applications
it is a visual development interface
platform and used for developing
applications without using any coding
experience
now let's dive into the top 10 no code
application builders so the first one in
the list is appipy
appy's no good app builder has managed
to democratize app making with its drag
and drop app builder software
mobile app development is now accessible
to all irrespective of coding knowledge
and everyone can make a mobile app with
apple pie app maker
it was founded by mr abhinav geridhar in
2015 and was located in walnut united
states
it acquired app maker merging app maker
with their development platform and
giving best results
this unique no code app builder from app
i has gained tremendous popularity
among tech and non-tech users due to its
fantastic ease of use and intuitive
interface
the major advantage of choosing apple
pie
is that the development it provides and
accessing the applications is also the
significant benefits of choosing this
apple pie
and the next one in the list is app
sheet app sheet is a no code development
platform that lets anyone without coding
experience build a mobile and web
application
it was founded by mr praveen sheishadri
in the year 2014 and it is located in
cfl washington
using app sheet you can build some
applications based on data sources such
as google sheets excel cloud sql
salesforce and other similar connectors
it captures data and formed by images
signatures barcodes and nfc the data is
automatically synced to the cloud-based
or the user can opt manually
one of the key advantages of using
appship is the multi-development and
data integration it provides and the
next one in the list is airtable
airtable is a cloud-based company for
developing applications using no code
development it integrates all the
applications and services it was founded
in the year 2012 by harvard liu andrey
offstar and amit nicholas located in san
francisco it is used to manage work
track and organize inventories and plan
an event
airtable is a spreadsheet database
hybrid with the feature of database but
applied to a spreadsheet the fields in
an air table are similar to cells in a
spreadsheet but have types such as check
box phone number and drop down list and
can reference file attachments like
images
airtable provides good customization and
integration for the applications which
is a major benefit to choose and the
next one in the list is lancer visual
lansa is a cloud-based application
development platform designed to help
software developers build
multi-experienced applications
it was founded in the year 1987 by peter
and lindsey to create and sell software
development tools for the ibm systems
visual lansa local development platform
enables companies to digitally transform
their business and increase id
efficiency while reducing risk and
technical depth enabling development to
finish on time and respond to demands
for more applications
visual lancer provides the best tools to
develop web applications and offers good
sql support for the applications created
and the next one in the list is
microsoft power platform microsoft power
platform is a great tool when you're
after the creation of business apps it's
quick and easy to design and develop
it was founded in the year 2018 and
released by microsoft which provides
integrations with github and teams
it is more than the sum of its parts
connect to office 365 dynamics 365 azure
and hundreds of other apps and build
end-to-end business solutions the data
integration and data storage it provides
as the key feature to choose microsoft
power platform and the next one in the
list is quick base quick base is a low
code platform that allows non-technical
developers to build customize and
connect scalable secure cloud
applications
mapped to unique business challenges
without compromising iit governance and
control
it was founded in the year 1999 by joe
jim and claudi
located in cambridge united states of
america the platform addresses a broad
set of business use cases through its
customizable application platform
including workflow and process
automation forms and personalized chats
and reports driven by customizable
business logic quick base provides good
access and best development features to
the applications created and which is a
major benefits to choose one
and next one in the list is dot bubble
dot bubble is a visual programming
language a no-code development platform
and an application platform as a service
developed by bubble group enabling
non-technical people to build web
applications without needing to type a
single code it was founded in the year
2012 by joshua haas and emmanuel located
in new york
users draw the interface by dragging and
dropping elements onto a page and
defining workflows to the control logic
bubble's vision is to make hand coding
for web applications largely obsolete
one of the major advantages of choosing
bubble is the speed of development and
easy application updates
and the next one in the list is mendix
mendex is an american low code software
platform company that provides tools to
build test deploy and iterate
applications
the company was founded by
derrick ross and derek jan in the year
2005 and later it was acquired by
simmons in 2018 and now it operates as
an independent subsidiary the mendix app
store also offers new widgets to access
native device functions such as contacts
camera geolocation and barcode scanner
the company also released the mendix
developer app to test mobile
applications the deployment and
development of the applications happen
in a speedy manner using mendix this is
the key benefit of choosing mendix and
the next one we have is test flow
case flow is one of the best workflow
automation software development
platforms that offer comprehensive
solutions
it was founded by mr suresh and launched
by orange space at google input output
in 2012
that is designed to work along with
google apps that provide user experience
with google apps such as gmail and
google docs
it provides a simple optimal and
efficient platform to manage and track
all your work case flow provides best
mobile support and administrative
support to the applications built
and next one in the list is soho creator
zoho corporation is an indian
multinational technology company that
makes web-based business tools it is
best known for its online office suit
named soho the company was founded in
the year 1996 by mr sridhar wembo and
tony thomas and had a presence in seven
locations with its global headquarters
in chennai tamil nadu india
and global headquarters in california
soho creator builds multi-platform
applications ranging from simple call
logs to complex erps that integrate with
your existing process
zoho provides a good security system and
best customer relationship management to
the applications created which is a
crucial feature to choose
now let's have a look at some of the
benefits of no code development
while building an application everyone
thinks about the cost no good
development helps reduce the issues
related to cost by lowering the budget
the no-code development requires less
effort which helps in reducing the
burden on the developers
making changes for the applications
using no-code development is easy and
done in less amount of time
building applications using other
development tools requires more
developers in the development team
but using the noku development requires
fewer developers comparatively
so this was all for today's session i
hope this session gave you an idea about
the importance of no good development
and the top 10 no good application
builders
if you guys have found it informative
and helpful do like and subscribe our
youtube channel
if you have any queries or questions do
let us know in the comment section below
and we have our experts to answer it
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more from simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here